ON TIME WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR
MEMBERS IN THE AUTHORS
.
DOING WELL HOW ARE YOU ALL AND
GOOD AFTERNOON AND A NOTION THAT
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM --
WILL START TO KEEP THE COMMITTEE
AS THEY ARE SUBCOMMITTEE OKAY.
THANK YOU MAN.
ALRIGHT VERY GOOD WILL GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE.
APPLY TO A BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THINKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR HARD WORK MUCH APPRECIATED.
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR WHAT
SUPPORT AND ACCELERATE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF BATTERY ELECTRIC
TRANSIT BUSES TRANSIT AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA REPLACING
CONVENTIONAL FUEL TRANSIT BUSES.
WITH BATTERY ELECTRIC TRANSIT
BUSES AS TRANSIT AGENCIES MOVED
TO SCALE UP THEIR DEPLOYMENT A
BATTERY ELECTRIC BUSES.
MANY HAVE FOUND THAT THE COST OF
ELECTRICITY EXCEEDS CONVENTIONAL
FUEL AND IS LESS PREDICTABLE.
THE COST AND UNPREDICTABILITY OF
ELECTRICITY AS A FUEL IS SLOWING
THE ADOPTION OF CLEANER ENERGY
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS VITAL TO
MEETING THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS AND IMPROVING OUR STATE'S
AIR QUALITY.
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
MORE THAN EIGHTY TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
HAS IDENTIFIED THE COST OF
ELECTRICITY AS ONE OF THE TOP
THREE BARRIERS TO TRANSIT
ELECTRIFICATION.
AS THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
CURRENTLY ADVANCING REGULATION
TO REQUIRE ALL EIGHT TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO PURCHASE ZERO
EMISSION BUSES.
THE NEED TO FIND A SOLUTION HAS
BECOME MORE URGENT SP FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOUR IS ESSENTIAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S GOALS OF
TRANSITIONING TO CLEANER ENERGY
REDUCING TOXIC.
POLLUTANTS IN THE AIR AND
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
AND INCLUDING THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
MICHAEL HIMSELF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION WORTHY
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION
SENATOR LEYVA DID A GOOD JOB OF
SUMMARIZING THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL.
I'M JUST GONNA NOTE --
THAT A VOTE FOR THIS BILL TODAY
IS A VOTE IN FAVOR OF
ACCELERATING THE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE DEPLOYMENT ZERO
EMISSION BUSES.
ON SOMETHING IT WILL RESULT IN
AIR QUALITY GAINS --
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OF
WOULD REQUIRE ONLY --
THAT THE I USE THAT HAVE NOT YET
FILED RATE DESIGN APPLICATIONS
THAT ENCOURAGE THEIR MISSION
VAST PLAN TO DO SO.
I'M WE THINK THAT HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION NOW WELL AGENCIES
ARE JUST SCALING UP THEIR
DEPLOYMENTS MAKES GOOD SENSE.
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
HONORABLE CHAIR IN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS QUIRK LIKE I I AM THE
CHAIRMAN A FERTILE TRANSIT A WE
ARE A TRANSIT AGENCY INSANELY
REBELLION LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
ACTUALLY COVER PART OF THE
SENATORS DISTRICT.
I'M JOINED TODAY BY OUR CEO DORM
BARNES AND MY FELLOW BOARD
MEMBERS CAROL HERRERA SAMPEDRO
SIR AND COREY WARSHAW.
OF OUR AGENCY HAS A GOAL OF
GOING ALL ELECTRIC BY THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY THIS WILL HELP US
MOVE TOWARDS ACHIEVING THAT
OBJECTIVE AND SO WE ALSO JOIN
AND THANK SENATOR LEYVA FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL.
AND WE JOIN WITH HER IN ASKING
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO MANY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AYE
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AS WELL
AS A SANTA CRUZ METROPOLITAN
TRANSIT DISTRICT.
BOTH IN SUPPORT WE THINK THIS IS
A GREAT BILL.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLELY
SHAUN BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY AND STRONG THIS WILL
HELP THE STATE MEETS ITS TRAP
MEETS IT AS TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION GOALS.
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO TEST
PINE SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IT'S BIG
BLUE BUS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE
TALK ON BEHALF ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS ARE SEIZE ME ONCE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS VINCENT WHERE MOTHER
WITH A WHITE IN A GROUP ON
BEHALF OF YOU IDEA AMERICA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HIGH CHAIR MEMBERS WERE BACK AND
WE ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION BUT WOULD LIKE
TO BE HERE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ROLLING OUT.
OUR MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY RACED TO
SUPPORT THE TRANS AGENCIES TO
ELECTRIFY THEIR FLEET THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DIVING OF
FLEMING'S ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR.
THE SPONSORS AND HER STAFF ON
THIS BILL WE THINK YOU FOR THE
AMENDMENTS WILL LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FORGET BACK THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT I HAVE A QUESTION.
PLEASE A SO YOU'VE AGREED TO
TAKE AMENDMENT THAT SAYS THE
RATE TARA FOR QUIET UNDER THIS
SECTION SHALL NOT RESULT IN COST
SHIFTS TO NON PARTICIPATING
CUSTOMERS CORRECT OUT WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN.
IT MEANS WE WON'T SHIFT THE
COSTS.
SO IT WASN'T MY AMENDMENT IT WAS
A IT WAS THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENT AND I JUST AND I
BELIEVE THAT'S RIGHT JUST MEANS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SHIP THE
COSTS YAKIMA SOMEONE'S GOT TO
PAY RIGHT IT DIDN'T WORK.
PROVIDING ELECTRICITY TO TRANSIT
AUTHORITIES AT BELOW MARKET
RATES THAT'S GOT IT THE MONEY'S
GOT TO COME FROM SOMEWHERE SO
WHERE WE'RE GONNA COME FROM IF
IT'S NOT SHIFTED TO NON
PARTICIPATING CUSTOMERS SO I CAN
PROVIDE SOME PERSPECTIVE ON THAT --
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON FOR
EXAMPLE HAS ADVANCED STATE WHAT
DESIGN PROPOSAL --
THAT WOULD RELIEVE AT THE CALL
DEMAND CHARGES [inaudible]
YOUR GENERATION YOUR YOUR DRAW
FROM THE GRID WHAT THEY'VE DONE
IS IN WAIVING THOSE THOSE FEES
THEY BAKE THEM INTO THEIR TIME
OF USE OF FEES WHICH ARE.
OF WHAT AGENCIES PAY BASED ON
ARMED SERVICES DRAWING OUT AT
CERTAIN POINTS OF THE DAY AND SO
WHAT YOU'RE ABLE TO DO IN A IN A
FACT IS ADDRESS SOME OF THE
FIXED COSTS IN AND BUILD THEM
INTO VARIABLE COSTS.
AND WITH THAT AND AND AGENCIES
STILL PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE
BUT SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
PREDICT MORE READILY AS OPPOSED
TO SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
A FIXED COST THAT WILL SPIKE.
DEPENDING ON THE DEMAND THAT
YOU'RE DRAWING AT ANY ONE POINT
IN TIME.
OKAY SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE
COST OF PROVIDING.
BELOW MARKET RATE ELECTRICITY
TRANSIT AUTHORITIES WILL BE
BAKED INTO A TIME OF USED COSTS
FOR COMPANIES THAT WOULD BE ONE
ONE ONE STRATEGY THAT COULD BE
USED --
WITHIN WITHIN THIS FRAMEWORK
WOULD THAT NOT BE A VIOLATION OF
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT
SAYS THAT IN THE WOULD THAT BE A
COST SHIFT THAT WOULD BE A NON
PARTICIPATING CUSTODY WOULD BE A
CHANGE.
IN THE WAY THAT COSTS ARE
ALLOCATED BUT THEY WOULD BE BORN
FULLY BY THE TRANSIT AGENCY.
I THINK WE'RE PROUD OF NOW NOW
I'M REALLY CONFUSED GO IT'S I
THINK THAT THE COMMITMENT IS IS
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO COST
SHIP THAT WE ARE GOING TO FIND A
WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PAY FOR
IT BUT WE'RE NOT SHIFTING IT TO
THOSE WHO MIGHT.
BE USING IT.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE A COMPLETE
ANSWER FOR IS WHAT I'M SAYING Y.
AND I'M I'M VERY SYMPATHETIC
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING THE
COMMITTEES.
ARE IS IS --
FOISTING ON YOU RIGHT SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THIS CAME FROM A
COMMITTEE AND NOT FROM THE
AUTHOR BUT IT IT PUTS ME IN A
DILEMMA BECAUSE MY BIG PROBLEM
WITH YOUR BILL.
IS THAT [inaudible]
HA.
ELECTRICITY ELECTRICITY RATES
ARE ALREADY IN CALIFORNIA OVER
50% HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
AND I DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
THAT'S GOING TO FURTHER INCREASE
THAT GAP BECAUSE I THINK IT
MAKES LIVING IN CALIFORNIA EVEN
LESS AFFORDABLE AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE I REPRESENT ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING SO.
A IT'S IT'S REFRESHING TO SEE
SOMETHING THAT SAYS THERE WILL
BE NO COST SHIFT BUT TO ME
THAT'S AN IMPOSSIBILITY BECAUSE
THE ELECTION THE UTILITY HAS TO
RECOVER ITS COSTS BEFORE
MANDATING.
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING A LOOK
BELOW MARK ELECTRICITY THAT
MONEY YOU KNOW WE COULD
LEGISLATE THAT A COFFEE CUPS NOT
A COFFEE CUP BUT YOU KNOW AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT'S GOT TO BE A
COFFEE CUP AT THE END OF THE
YEAR.
AYE I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING HOW
THERE CAN'T BE SOME KIND OF COST
SHIFT TO RECOVER THOSE FUNDS.
WELL I AM EVER HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN ALWAYS FIND A WAY TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT WE SAID WE WOULD DO
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS THAT SAY THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO COST* KASHIF
THAT WE'RE GOING HAVE TO FIND
WOULD NOT DO THAT.
WELL WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY IT
EITHER BAKE IT IN OR SOME OTHER
MECHANISM OKAY WELL.
RESPECTFULLY PACOLLI ONLY SEE
TWO TWO POSSIBILITIES EITHER A
CUSTOMER PAYS OR THE UTILITY
PAYS [inaudible]
AND THE THE ALL OF THE OTHER
THAN THAT IT'S THERE'S THERE'S
GOTTA COME FROM SOMEWHERE AND I
I THINK I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY SAY THAT WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING.
IF WE CONTINUE DOWN THE PATH
WHERE YOU LIVE JUST AT OUTSIDE
YOUR DISTRICTS JUST ATTACHED TO
MINE AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
SOME OF THE WORST POLLUTION IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE THAN ANYWHERE.
IF WE DON'T FIND A WAY TO MAKE
IT MORE AFFORDABLE FOR THESE
BUSES TO OPERATE ELECTRICALLY
THEN WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
POLLUTE THE AREAS OF BOTH YOU
AND I LIVE IN.
AND MARK ARE A CONSTITUENTS LIVE
AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
BIGGEST OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF
ASTHMA IN THE INLAND EMPIRE THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WILSON OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAS
EXTREMELY HIGH RATES SO I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT SO THAT WE CAN
DO THE BEST WE CAN SURE A AND I
THINK WE ARE ALL IN AGREEMENT
THAT WE WANT.
TO INCENTIVIZE THE PRODUCTION OF
MORE TRANSIT THAT ZERO MISSION
BUT JUST A QUESTION OF HOW WE
GET THERE THAT WE'RE DEBATING
TODAY ALWAYS THE QUESTION
[inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
I I'M GONNA FIGURE SOME OF THE
VICE CHAIRMAN'S CONCERNS HERE
SENATOR --
THEN IN IRAQ WE HAVE A HUGE
ASTHMA PROBLEM HE'S AIR QUALITY
PROBLEM --
ESPECIALLY THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
AND BE YOU KNOW ONE OF MY CITIES
PORTERVILLE --
BROUGHT AND GREEN BOSTON IS
DOING ELECTRIC BUTTON AND
FIGURED OUT A WAY.
THEIR BUT WHEN WE USE
TERMINOLOGY LIKE BAY CAN --
TO ME THAT'S JUST.
SCREAMING THAT IT'S GONNA COST
SHIFT TO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY.
YEAH YOU KNOW FOLKS IN MY
DISTRICT ARE.
AVERAGE INCOMES THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND A YEAR.
AND SUMMER ELECTRIC BILLS ALL
OUR OVER FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH.
A LIMITED AND THAT JUST LIKE
THAT TOO AND IN A CAUTIOUS THAT.
YOU NOT QUITE FRANKLY YOU KNOW
WHEN HAVE 24% CALIFORNIANS
LIVING IN POVERTY A ANY THEIR
CONCERN IS MORE SO KEEP IT COOL
IN THEIR HOUSE AND KEEPING FOOD
ON THE TABLE FOR THE KIDS. NINE
IN OTHER INNER WEARING THEIR
WORD ABOUT THE AIR BUT MEMORY
ABOUT TAKING CARE THEIR FAMILY.
BY IN THE LATE GREAT ANYTHING
THAT'S GOING TO PROVIDE A COST
SHIFT IS IS.
WORRISOME --
I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU AS IF
YOUR BILL MOST FOR DAMN SURE YOU
GOT YOUR VOTES TO DO IT --
MAYBE LOOK AT SOMETHING THAT
WOULD INCENTIVIZE.
THE COMPANY'S SAN AND GIVE THEM
SOME KIND OF A TAX BREAK OR
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES --
WHAT WERE THEY GOING TO CREDIT
BACK FOR DOING THIS SO INSTEAD
OF SHIFTING THE COSTS OF THE ONE
WHO I DON'T WILL MARKET SHIP WE
WE CAN?
POSSIBLY GIVE THESE COMPANIES A
BREAK UP FOR DOING SOMETHING TO
HELP US AS A STATE MOVE FOR
TECHNOLOGICALLY.
VERSE SAYS POSSIBLY HURTING THE
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
HELP THAT TOTALLY AGREE LET ME
BE CLEAR AGAIN WE ARE NOT
LOOKING TO COST SHIFT I THINK
THAT'S WHY THAT MY AMENDMENT WAS
PUT INTO THE BILL.
AND IT'S ALWAYS A GOOD IDEA TO
LOOK OF INCENTIVE INCENTIVES ARE
BETTER THE CARE IS BETTER THAN
THE STICK AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE CARROT ON THE FLOOR
BLAIR TOGETHER TO STICK SUMMIT
STAND OFF THAT.
ARE EVER GONNA TAKE A MOMENT
ESTABLISH QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE HERE [inaudible]
BONTA CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF LOVE
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS HERE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
QUICKSILVER [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM BRING
ABOUT COMMITTEE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY AS A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THERE'S NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
MEMSIC.
GOING MR MAIENSCHEIN JUST JUST
VERY QUICKLY I YOU KNOW I HAVE
SOME OF THE SAME CONCERNS I AM
GONNA SUPPORT IT TODAY --
BECAUSE OF THE PROVISION THAT'S
IN THERE I AGREE IT'S YOU KNOW
THERE IS SOME VAGUENESS THERE
ARE BAD.
IN I TRUST AUTHOR THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT AND THAT I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
BUT THAT THE STATE GOES FOR FOR
THE REASONS STATED --
IT IF THERE DOESN'T SEEM YOU
KNOW IT'S SOMETHING THAT MAYBE
IS A IF IT GOES THROUGH IT AS
THIS PROCEEDS THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF BAD HASN'T WORKED OUT
MAKE A BACK.
AND REVISIT IT IN THE MEANTIME
WE'RE NOT SUPPORT IT TODAY THANK
YOU FAIR ENOUGH.
AND OTHER QUESTIONS.
HER NON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DEPOSITS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE NO OBERNOLTE NO BONTA
[inaudible]
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN.
HOLDEN NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW.
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO PATTESON.
PATTERSON NO QUICKSILVER
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible] HUNDRED SI.
IT'S FOR THREE THE MEASURES ON
CALL.
THE USER.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
.
I DON'T THINK.
THANK YOU PAT.
THANK YOU WORK [inaudible]
CREATE [inaudible]
REAL PROGRAMMERS.
I HAVE NO.
DOUBT THAT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE WHOLE [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
NOW
CHECK [inaudible]
SURE.
I TOLD THEM
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA LET THE CALL ON
FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE FOR
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR LEYVA.
BUSH'S DEPOSITS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATION [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
THROUGH THE MEASURE SO UNCLE
.
LIFT THE CALL ON S. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR S. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR DEPOSITS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
QUICKSILVER.
QUIRK SILVA AYE
.
SENATE THREE MEASURES OUT
ATTORNEY IN.
THE COMMITTEE